we must decide that we will not stop
we will not rest until our american
heritage of freedom
liberty and justice is once again safe
and once again secure
that was former president trump at the
closing day of the conservative
political action conference also known
as cpac he continues to show his
dominance of republican politics
easily winning the cpac straw poll
beating out his closest challenger
that's florida governor
ron desantis now we're learning new
details about mr trump's final year in
office
and his current life in the new book
frankly we did win this election
the inside story of how trump lost by
journalist michael c
bender the book paints a picture of
chaos during the pandemic
the 2020 presidential campaign and
protests after george floyd's death
it also portrays a presidential staff
struggling to keep their boss
on message bender writes of a 2018
conversation in worcester
which mr trump's then chief of staff
john kelly
briefed him on the history of the first
world war and its connections with world
war
ii bender says trump replied well hitler
did a lot of good things a stunned kelly
told the president
you cannot ever say anything supportive
of adolf hitler you just can't
in another section bender details
president trump's immediate reaction
to the video showing george floyd's
murder bender recalls a repulsed
trump turning away from the video saying
this is blanking
terrible he later tweeted his support
for the floyd family saying
justice will be served the book's author
senior white house reporter for the wall
street journal michael c
bender joins us now first on cbs this
morning michael thanks so much for being
with us
um we should say first that mr trump has
called the reports in your book
totally false but you did interview the
former president and some 150 former
staff members
friends and advisors what what is your
biggest takeaway from the final year in
the trump white house
it was what revealed itself to me in
reporting this book
is um is how dangerous the people around
the president thought he was for the
country and and
everyone knows the story of of the chaos
of this administration
yeah but i what i don't think people
understand what i think this this this
book really details
is is what a danger that the people he
was closest to thought he was
um when it came to um wanting to put
military
on the streets um and um you know
wanting to
obfuscate the details of covid um
and you you mentioned the the attacks on
the book um
the president has um complimented my
hair
he's that's the basis of our
relationship repeatedly yeah and so i'm
very glad that he at least didn't
disparage uh
my hairdo but but but the president
knows
that um i talked spent a lot of time
talking to people very close to him yes
how much time did you spend talking to
the president by the way oh i went down
to mar-a-lago twice
yeah um and i was down there for several
hours each time
he was very very gracious with his time
uh he invited me to dinner
uh the the first night we were there um
so
you know he he's aware of what's in the
book we've talked about what's in the
book
uh and he knows that that people who
don't normally talk to journalists
were talking to me for this book it was
also interesting to see how there was
such
backbiting and competition behind the
scenes with the people closest to him
you talk about
jared ivanka eric you talk about
kellyanne conway
can you take us behind behind the scenes
about those relationships
because it was very competitive and very
nasty this is the
world that trump created around himself
where the
the the litmus test to work for trump
was loyalty to him not loyalty to the
country
not loyalty to the constitution but the
lengths that you would go to
to defend the president the loyalty that
seemed to work one way by the way
but go ahead yeah there's i i think
that's right too
um and and and what what the book shows
here in some of the details and stories
in this
in this book show that that's how what
kind of brings us to january 6th
and very few people around him were
willing to
to stand up and tell him point blank uh
what was right and what was wrong now
mike one thing that your book does is it
really puts us
inside these spaces i felt like a fly on
the wall in air force one when the
president's looking at the george floyd
video for the first time and he's
shaken and repulsed and couldn't even
finish watching it
but then there was a tone shift where he
started you know
using more aggressive language against
protesters your e-book says
you know we should crack their skulls
what was his rationale between
going from his personal reaction of
sympathy to this harder stance publicly
yeah i appreciate that i i do think that
that this is a very crowded space of
trump books trump uh
is saturated the media from day one but
what i think that
this book does is is going to be the
only one that takes us behind the scenes
of how he managed the country uh how the
campaign
struggled to uh catch up to biden in the
final days despite
being a two billion dollar operation and
and spends time with
uh a very hardcore section of the trump
base
um to start to show uh and understand
what happened on january 6th
and what brought us to this point and
and explain why
uh what trump saw as his um you know
political calling card which was a very
law and order uh tough message you spoke
to
to mr trump about about his relationship
with mike pence
um which obviously got very strained uh
in those final days
did you asked him directly about whether
he put pence on the ticket again if he
runs again
yeah i was struck the second time i
spoke to president trump
um that at that point he and mike pence
had spoken by
phone uh half a dozen times the
president was reaching out
to mike pence um and someone who
he had described to his supporters as
basically a traitor to the country
yes so striking to me that that he had
reached out so i wanted to know if
um he would uh he would run with him
again um
and if he expected pence to apologize
um for upholding the constitution and
uh it was striking to me that that the
president would not
touch that issue he didn't he he's he's
not ready to make a decision
about 2024. you know what's interesting
is that in 2016
team trump thought they were going to
lose in 2020 they thought they were
going to win
and after he didn't win you said he goes
from being leader of the free world to
you called the king of mar-a-lago that
when he got there he just really didn't
know what to do
what is his life like now because you
said he does seem to be
sort of trying to figure out his next
move yeah there's a there's a very long
scene in the book
um of what is happening in mar-a-lago
particularly those first few months
after the presidency he he arrived in
south florida at his at his
beachfront home really unprepared for
post-presidency life
um this staff was brought into a room to
set up shop where there was mattresses
on the floor they had to go and find
their own
desks uh at office depot
and places like that uh and it took
trump a while to
um find a routine again and what he's
done um not surprisingly
is what he loves play golf he plays up
to 36 holes a day
um you know some some some famous
golfers come down to play with him
and um and we're seeing more and more
he's getting back on the rally scene
during his during his uh presidency he
knocked barack obama's
playing golf and trump certainly out did
that you said his
his shamelessness was his political
super it was his political superpower
yeah that's right and shameless you said
that's right he's he's willing to
to to say and and and do things that
other politicians
um were not and that's not necessarily
my
uh analysis that's that's what jared
kushner identified very quickly
as as a a positive a political positive
for
for for this president right michael c
bender thank you so much for being with
us thank you
and bringing your nice hair it is nice
frankly we did win this election goes on
sale tomorrow you're watching cbs this
morning
we'll be right back